Donald Trump has been indicted again and
you're gonna love this everybody he's
being indicted by the Biden doj for
trying to wipe a server I kid you not it
is beautiful irony and I'm just I gotta
be honest I'm very very glad they did it
because you know it's only going to be a
matter of days maybe maybe hours until
Hillary Clinton gets indicted for
actually having her server deleted and
phone smashed with hammers now I suppose
the the reason they're indicting Trump
for this is so they can make the
argument that hey you you claimed for
years that that wiping a server was a
criminal act and here's Trump trying to
do it now you have to be against Trump
but it actually does the inverse now I'm
gonna be like you said no reasonable
prosecutor would bring charges against
Hillary so clearly you are not
reasonable prosecutors right now we got
this big story about Hunter Biden they
tried sneaking in an unprecedented
blanket immunity deal for Hunter on all
charges and the judge caught it